انجاز يشبه المعجزه اعاده الامل بالمشي
بطريقه طبيعيه لذوي التشوهات بالعمود
الفقري الطبيب المصري هاني عبد الجواد
ارتبط اسمه باجراء جراحات اعوجاج العمود
الفقري الخطيره والتي رفضها اطباء اخرون
ايناس طفلته سودانيه اصبحت اليوم ايناس
جديده هي قالت ذلك في سعاده وهي تقف سليمه
بجوار والدها والدكتور هاني انتشرت صورها
بشكل كبير على مواقع التواصل قبل وبعد
العمليه الخطيره التي غيرت من شكلها تماما
من ايناس الى الفتاه الاماراتيه هند
والشاب احمد والطفله هناء كلها جراحات
اعاده لاصحابها طعم الحياه
[موسيقى]
ايناس زي ما حضراتكم شفتم كان عندها نوع
من التحدث النادر جدا
ودخل لها موطيه لاكثر من مستوى الركوع
يعني
النادر عند ايناس ان التحدب بتاع العمود
الفقري ده شيء ما هواش نادر ده شيء شائع
موجود عند كتير من الشباب ولكن مهما كانت
درجه التحدب كبير ومهما كانت الحاله خطيره
ده ما بيخليش الشاب يوطي زي ايناس كده فهي
ايناس كانت حاله فريده من نوعها
وده كان اللغز اللي عند ايناس ان احنا
يعني دايما حالات التحدب ديت بيبقى عمليات
حسابيه يعني هنعمل كذا فنحصل على نتيجه
كذا فهو صعب عند ايناس كان ان احنا ناخد
قرار لانها حاله فريده جدا ان هنعمل ايه
فناخد النتيجه ايه يعني لحد انا ما طلعت
من العمليه وانا واثق ان انا عملت حاجه
كويسه مش متاكد ان هي هتقدر تستقيم فهو ده
كان
الغريب في ايناس يعني دكتور هاني فقط يعني
لكي نستفسر عن المشكله من الاساس هل هذه
مشكله تبدا مع الولاده ام تاتي في كحاله
نادره مثلا تطرا على جسد الانسان
اش على السؤال لان ده هو التحدب دهوت ده
ليه انواع عديده جدا في تحدد بيكون نتيجه
ااا فقره مشوهه
منذ الولاده فالفتره المشوهه منذ الولاده
ده بيبدا يمنع عن نفسه على طول وفي تحدد
بيبدا يجي مع النمو يعني بيطرا يبقى الطفل
عادي جدا ويجي مع النمو يبدا يحصل له تحدد
والتحدد دهوت بيزيد وفي تحدد بيكون ثانوي
لبعض الامراض فالتحدب له انواع عديده يعني
دكتور ايناس استطاعت الوقوف بعد ست ساعات
من اجراء العمليه تحديدا هل يمكن القول
انه ايناس عادت الى حالتها الطبيعيه وهناك
انتصاب كامل للعمود الفقري والظهر اه
الحقيقه يعني هو دي كانت المفاجاه الكبيره
ان هو يعني انا فعلا زي ما قلت لحضرتك ان
انا بعد ما طلعت من العمليه انا مش قادر
استنى عايز اروح اوقفها يعني
ايناس كانت الصبح بتمشي موطيه بطريقه
رهيبه جدا وبس عشان نفهم موضوع موطيه ده
يعني لو حد ما عندوش حاجه يعني هو ما
عندوش حاجه خالص ولكن حاول يمشي بطريقه
التغطيه دهيت لمده دقيقه واحده لا يحتملها
البنت كان بقى لها اكثر من سنه ونص بتمشي
بالطريقه ديت فكان ان هي تستقيم همم سنه
ونص مش عارفه حتى تنام على ظهرها فكان ان
هي تستقيم وان هي تطلع من العمليات نايمه
على ضهرها ده كان لوحده
انجاز او فرحه كبيره بالنسبه لنا كلنا بقى
احساسي كده
[موسيقى]